good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-401
object class euclid
special containment procedures scp-401
is to be kept in an enclosed courtyard
at site a mural of the landscape of
southern france is painted on the walls
of the courtyard
once daily personnel are to locate at
least 10 roots which will be fed a total
of 15 liters of nutritional supplement
for a 1 ns4 and to remove any solid
waste
produced an ekg is to constantly monitor
scp-401 for any anomalies
refer to incident 401-1 for details
female personnel are not to enter the
courtyard at any time
between march 15th and april 1st under
any circumstances
description scp-401 was discovered near
the french
city of when agents responded to reports
of the ground bleeding
when led to the site investigators found
a human mouth embedded in the soil
licking away the remaining blood with a
long prehensile
tongue it was not until a week later
that agents realized that the mouth was
part of a root structure
of what at first appeared to be a 40
meter tall
dead eucalyptus tree with branches
shaped like multi-jointed human arms
the white color of the trunk originally
suggesting that the tree was dead
was found to be because the bark was
made of human bone tissue it was given
scp status and evacuated from the area
to be transported to site
scp-401 resembles an ordinary tree in
form and function however human
physiology is substituted for plant
biology
in the fulfillment of necessary
processes
the trunk is supported by multiple
vertebral columns
woven together by tendons and muscles
and coated by a layer of rough bone
tissue
also held together by flexible tendons
as one goes higher the trunk will split
repeatedly
until there is a single vertebral column
supporting the rest of the structure
at the base of the trunk are multiple
human hearts which pump blood and
nutrients through the roots and branches
the roots themselves are esophagi
protected by a layer of cartilage
reminiscent of the trachea
at the end of each root is a fully
formed upper and lower jaw
complete with muscles lips and the
prehensile tongue first witnessed by
agents in the field
the tongue seems to be used as a digging
implement and as a snare for food
ranging from burrowing animals to edible
fungi
and plants all of these roots are
ultimately led to a single stomach
this along with a fully functional
though unusually long intestinal tract
work to absorb ingested nutrients solid
waste is eliminated through a
sphincteral orifice on the side of the
trunk
no roots are found in the area
immediately beneath this spot
the branches as initial observations
suggested
are human arms they extrude themselves
from the bony trunk
but have no bark themselves some will
split at the elbows so that they may
have two
or even three forearms the palms of its
hands all face upward
and the tip of each finger has a human
eye growing from it
the iris of each eye is hazel dissection
of the eyes
shows that they are all myopic though
they do react
to light stimuli as a normal eye would
though the chemical process is not yet
understood
the retinas carry on a form of
photosynthesis which
transforms carbon dioxide and water into
oxygen and glucose it is generally
agreed that the eyes are myopic
in order to prevent excessive damage to
the retina
from direct sunlight chemical analysis
of the lungs
show that there is a higher oxygen
content when scp-401 exhales
than when it inhales during spring
scp-401 will go into bloom though it is
genetically a human male
it will grow female sexual organs the
vaginal openings are located on the
palms of its hands
with canals extending 18 centimeters
along each wrist
to a bulge which contains a fully formed
uterus
and ovaries five days after the
formation of the organs
menstruation occurs at which point male
sexual organs begin to develop in their
place
over a period of 10 days once fully
formed they will remain for one day
before they are shed
and eaten by the roots during this phase
scp-401 will attack human females
for the purpose of reproduction
experiment log 401 1
the fact that scp-401 is genetically
human
combined with the violence exhibited
against women during its male phase
suggests that it may be compatible with
human beings
a number of breeding experiments have
been proposed to test this
date subject female d-class personnel
d-2055 procedure
d-2055 was artificially inseminated with
material produced by scp-401
during mail phase the product of this
was allowed to gestate
details nine months after conception
d2055 gave birth to a normal human male
infant though healthy and lacking in any
unusual physiology
the child has been found to suffer from
severe myopia
comparable to what was estimated with
the eyes of scp-401
the child has been adopted by agent who
has agreed to bring
junior to a foundation approved doctor
for monthly physical examinations
experiment log 401 2
date subject
male d-class personnel d-2067
procedure d-2067 was ordered to donate
genetic material
which was used to artificially
inseminate scp-401
at the beginning of its female phase
this was allowed to gestate
details 12 hours after insemination the
uterine bulge in the wrist
increased in size by 300 percent
while the other branches continued to
develop normally for the next two weeks
the inseminated arm retained its uterine
bulge
and vaginal canal 24 hours prior to
maturation of male organs
the uterine bulge began contracting
until a massive tissue
was extracted from the palm this was
thrown over the edge of the courtyard by
the arm which had given birth
the appendage was then shed and absorbed
by the roots minutes later
after five hours of searching personnel
found the item which was thrown
a human urinary bladder with a fetus
nestled inside
consistent with one that had been
gestating for two months
the bladder was planted in soil it
germinated two days later
and became a seedling equivalent to
scp-401 in structure the organism died
of malnutrition one week later
despite being fed nutritional supplement
401
ns3 experiment log 401
3 date subject
female d-class personnel 2081
procedure an egg was removed from
scp-2081's ovary
fertilized with genetic material
harvested from scp-401
and frozen until next spring the
fertilized egg was implanted into
scp-401
and allowed to gestate details
nutritional supplement 401 ns4 has been
formulated
with this development in mind incident
401
one on several of scp-401's branches
went into convulsions
and then went limp it was soon
discovered that one of its hearts
suffered from cardiac arrest
and was not able to recover an angiogram
of the other hearts
showed large amounts of plaque buildup
since incident 401
the damaged heart has been absorbed and
two new hearts have grown in its place
in order to maintain the future health
of scp-401
a lower cholesterol nutritional
supplement 401
ns3 has been approved which has been
stricken from the document
nutritional supplement 401 and s4 is now
to be used
following the results of experiment 401
3.
a pregnant tree you'd think you'd get
used to this kind of [ __ ]
but you really don't you really don't
anyway this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you were all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
cesar hintern zarguran
onyx arbiter seoul
the morrigan retalias
karim el ashmoy the alpha walrus
patrick bailey dreams
matthew gilmore eric corbidge
kawaii fire keeper joker corvus
king madding james saba
and nj vojak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogue thank you
you